this is king.com the tallest roller
coaster in the world at 139 meters it's
nearly the height of the Great Pyramid
of Giza but what if we built a roller
coaster even taller what if there was a
coaster that went as high as the tallest
building on earth the Burj Khalifa well
it's a good thing we don't because
strapping into a ride like that might be
the last thing you ever did the true
limit of a rollercoasters height has
less to do with engineering and more to
do with the limits of the human body
because the higher the roller coaster
the faster you'll drop under gravity and
on our 800 meter tall mega coaster
riders would hit the blistering top
speed of 370 kilometers per hour going
this fast the wind alone would cause
serious damage for comparison here's
what a wind tunnel does to a human face
your skin would pull back at the cheeks
your eyes would be seeing a lot of
damage with if there is debris in the
air or anything like that and your ears
would probably start popping which
wouldn't be fun some of this is already
a problem for formula Rossa the fastest
roller coaster in the world
it reaches a top speed of 240 km/h
anyone who rides it has to wear goggles
to protect their eyes because at those
speeds dust and debris in the air turn
into tiny missiles speaking of missiles
dust and debris wouldn't be the only
problem the main thing I'd be worried
about is if you had a bird strike yes a
bird strike it's rare but it can happen
[Music]
at lower speeds it could leave you with
a bad bruise or a painful welt like with
the king Dakar rider but at 370 km/h you
and the unfortunate bird would likely
die from the collision now you could
just wear a motorcycle helmet and
protective clothing before strapping in
but there's another problem that no
amount of protective gear could fix
g-force it's the force that makes you
feel heavier than normal like when
you're riding through a coaster loop
normally you experience one g-force but
when you rapidly accelerate like when
you're going through a coaster loop the
g-force ramps up which causes blood to
rush away from your head and often makes
riders feel light-headed for this reason
most rollercoasters don't subject you to
more than five g's tops but we're not
talking about your typical coaster if
you enter a loop on the Khalifah coaster
at more than 300 km/h what we'll start
to move away from your head into the
rest of your body and that means you'll
start to gray out and then possibly
blackout and so what can engineers do to
protect riders as they continue to build
taller faster coasters the boring option
is to slow down the ride by adding
brakes along the first drop but there's
a better more exciting way around the
problem loops really big loops all you
have to do is manipulate the curvature
to maintain the g-forces that we want so
instead of a tight loop that UN Seattle
on a low-speed roller coaster you need
big swooping loops and large radius
curvature to make sure that you're not
generating huge amounts of g-force at
that speed and as you go through the
roller coaster and you lose speed due to
air resistance and drag in the wheels
your speed drops and
your curvature will get tighter that's
why many rollercoasters start with one
big loop followed by a series of faster
lighter ones though in theory our
Khalifa coaster is writable as long as
we add big enough loops and hand out
protective eye gear that said we'll
probably never see a roller coaster get
much taller than they are today because
nowadays there are cheaper and more
efficient ways to thrill and terrify
riders for example hydraulic or magnetic
launching systems accelerate riders to
extreme speeds without needing to build
an expensive giant drop so perhaps the
only reason to ever build something like
a Khalifa coaster would be for the view
I love roller coasters with beautiful
views and it adds so much to the
experience having a view on the way up
so any beautiful location love to see a
roller coaster in order to get a
different perspective on those bees